[Music]
welcome to another episode of the
outdoor boys YouTube channel it seems
like only last week that we were doing a
two and a half thousand mile road trip
it was last week so here we are on the
road again this time we're heading up to
Pennsylvania I'm going to be doing some
carp fishing with a fishing guide Joe
Raymond and I'm going to take my boat to
get serviced while I'm up there and
bringing the whole family long we get a
hotel and make a weekend of it so
hopefully we won't go all crazy being in
the car for another three hours
Oh guys the driving is terrible just
barely left Virginia Here I am at FNS
Yamaha marine here in Pennsylvania drop
in my boat off to get serviced and then
we're gonna keep heading north and go to
hotel check in and go car fishing
tomorrow they take care all right Tommy
really wanted me to take video of some
long horse up here cows
well guys we're here you guys ready to
go on check in the hotel okay we've done
this before huh get some dinner there we
go we're going to the Tokyo cafe in
preparation for our trip to Japan we're
gonna do some some Japanese food it's
our train and Tommy
[Music]
they made chopsticks for you see you
going this you know they go we've got
the kids to bed Jacob down I might
actually get some sleep for the first
time in a long time but then we're
getting up nice and early and we're
gonna be fishing at 7:00 in the morning
so
good night guys I am on the banks of the
Susquehanna River here with Joe Raymond
and we are gonna go after some big old
Susquehanna carp and gold gold diggin
guys Joe here is a professional
smallmouth bass guide and he wants to he
wants to dabble in the carp side with me
and and we're gonna kind of go back to
the roots here fish it and yeah and just
see if we can't load up on some big carp
and and anyway we're gonna have some fun
doing yeah absolutely
[Music]
you got that you bringing that Tommy
wait a man up on that and Tommy has a
rock it's a fossil
[Music]
yeah susquehanna is a very shallow river
compared to what lot of you guys are
used to
you don't go full throttle on this river
unless you know what you're doing
[Music]
is it new helix 10 side imaging yeah
that's pretty good
I'm seeing little stuff right in there
which is probably bass or other things
that the bottom looks good looks like
it's we got rock and sand and that sands
what we're gonna want check out this
side imaging sonar that's that's a tire
that's a tire and that's a tire there's
three tires on the bottom all right yeah
that's a rock there are four tires on
the bottom of the I know what you guys
are doing here in Pennsylvania that
right there is the fish is some sort
right there that's a deep sea you see
the shadow hydraulic anchors they're
just big Pistons that goes straight down
into the bottom there's two of them
just that push of a button you're
anchored up that is nice stuff okay guys
we're here about 15 minutes nobody
nothing really going on we're gonna pull
up and try another spot
[Music]
yeah alright guys so we got a sweet
little spot here we've basically let the
current push this up against this this
big rock ledge here and the water comes
through and it drops down and slows down
right here so there's a lot of little
deep pockets and we're sitting here
enjoying some pizza that we had
delivered Bankside here but I gotta tell
you something really cool though is I
don't know if you could see in here in
this grass there's tons of little
crayfish in there little about that long
and those things are great bait bass
love them carp love them catfish love
them everything loves a crayfish yeah
there's one right there crawling up oh
they're fast how many get two or three
hello I guess that's just the little
ones all right guys
where you gonna try another spot this
sticking and moving
Oh could be this might be the only one
so we'll have to share it hey keep your
odd tip up and keep that rod tip up
buddy roll real fast
that's a smallmouth no I'm dead serious
you got a smallmouth on that
smallmouth on corn hey the next time a
smallmouth trip doesn't go the way I
want it to maybe I'll just get some
ground so the wall is if you catch one
of these things right now you're not
supposed to take it out of the water so
technically it's still in the water
popcorn carp rate we're gonna have a
z-man swim bait take a work see if Tommy
can rip the swim bait tug-of-war so Z
mass Z man who z man all right Tommy
you see but you can break that trying
pool don't let go really pool come on
don't let it go come on come on Tommy
break it come on Tommy
you got to get them facial expressions
if break it come on pool let's see if it
goes back let it go that's pretty tough
all right guys I just had a first here I
got a little bit of a snag so I tugged
it free look what came back everything
but my lead but it was an inline lead so
I have the insert the line and
everything the hook still on the end but
my inline love is gone
being hard on equipment I think Michael
Blaine just stole my his just told my
lead i carp street magic just happened
we gave it a good go but then just not
not quite here but I'm really excited to
try this again sometime man this is a
beautiful river and it's just so carpi
it's just I got you know they're around
here somewhere but Joe here is an
awesome smallmouth bass guy this guy
just can't turn it off we're catching
smallmouth bass on card fishing gear so
he's a machine
[Music]
I say I'd like to tell you that is so
much fun riding in that boat is a
beautiful river its weather's gorgeous I
mean we have only caught one bass but I
had a lot of fun doing it you know we
just turned and burn spots but it's the
weather's beautiful out on that boat Joe
is a great guy to hang out with no
regrets at all but we still caught a
really nice smallmouth on the carp care
so that's kind of cool
well we're gonna hurry up get cleaned up
head back to the hotel
Mama's wondering where we're at we're
gonna go do a little swimming hey guys
if you'd like to catch some awesome
smallmouth bass here in the Susquehanna
River
check out Joe's Facebook page and
Instagram account put all of his
information in the video description and
take them out guys it's a great time
thanks guys he such a good guide he can
even catch smallmouth on car beer
[Music]
gotta get going home we have a long
drive oh we had a good time but it is
time to head back to Virginia look at
this this is how much stuff we bring for
like one evening we're insane take movie
in the army thanks for watching we hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you'd
like to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video